So why is building software matter?
Historically, it used to be that
building was just compiling and
packing your source code.
Today, builds are responsible for
so much more.
They run our tests, can buy coded
resources from multiple sources,
generate documentation,
create multiple build variance,
publish our applications,
and manage dependencies.
Because of this, the build has
become the software factory,
in which we can continually change,
test, and release our apps.
Think of Gradle as the one stop shop for
defining and
integrating all the parts of
your software delivery process.
For example, for Gradle users, the
process that executes the modern IDs,
like Android studio, or
CI front end products like Jenkins,
is all defining Gradle.
In this day and age,
an app store Android developer unable to
ship changes into production faster and
faster will fail behind the competition,
in the end automation is
the key to making this happen.
So why Gradle?
The biggest reason is that Google has
selected Gradle as the build system for
Android Studio.
In fact, Android Studio
delegates the entire process of
building Android Apps to Gradle.
When I hit the run button, Android
Studio just sets Gradle in motion and
sits back to watch.
By learning about Gradle,
we can extend this default behavior
to build even more and more capable and
well tested Android apps.
Obviously, Google is full
of very smart engineers.
And one measure of their smarts is
that they felt they didn't need to
reinvent the wheel with build systems.
Gradle solves some the most hard
problems faced by Android developers.
How to automate building and testing
apps to achieve rapid productivity.
And how to manage dependencies and
variations that allow professional
developers to pump out
dozens of variances of their apps with
one click, or build a suite of apps and
deal officially with
apps that are very large.
Another key insight is that
many Android developers work in
header genius environments.
With differing and
complex technology stacks,
Gradle is the dominant multi
platform build system.
Other strengths of Gradle
include the compact and
powerful build language used
to write its build scripts and
the rich domain model that allows
Gradle to reason about your build.